[Music]
developing tonight metro police looking
for suspects involved in a deadly
shooting in the northeast valley it
happened at park at a park i should say
near lamb and owens madison kimbrough is
live at metro headquarters with who
police are looking for tonight madison
yeah this all happened around six this
evening around douglas a selby park
according to metro a hispanic man in his
20's was walking on a pedestrian bridge
over the las vegas wash when a group of
men approached him and got into some
physical argument as the man was running
away one of the men in the group ran
after him and shot and killed him on the
bridge that's when the group dispersed
they then fled in two separate vehicles
one of those vehicles was stopped by las
vegas city marshals several miles away
from here and we have a couple people
detained however i'm not con at this
point positive as far as their
involvement in the incident
it's still unclear if the victim lived
in the area or if he knew the group of
men this is an ongoing investigation so
we will keep you updated on air and
online as soon as we learn the latest
details reporting live madison kimbrough
8 news now